so welcome back to the iced coffee hour
with Graham Jack and we got financial
education Jeremy now for those that
don't know you you got a YouTube channel
it's called financial education and then
you have financial education to this
we're gonna be going into some of your
background but also in this episode
we're gonna be talking about the stock
market how you got started how you built
your wealth
pretty significantly I would say over
the last few years doing YouTube
full-time what you think is a good
investment right now we're gonna be
talking about the the roni rona
situation who's smoking right no Joker's
wrong some of the worst investments
you've made some of the best investments
you've made whether or not it's worth it
to go to college what else am I
forgetting gambling oh yeah gambling how
graham always wins and not always lose
no it's amazing it's gonna be an
exciting episode is there anything else
I missed that we're gonna be talking
about today there's a lot more than that
but I think that's some of it oh yeah so
you guys we're gonna talk about her oh
yeah we're gonna talk about her so it's
gonna be a really interesting episode
but first let's start with this welcome
back to the iced coffee our folks a Holy
Smoke is this ain't no joke as I am on
the podcast with mr. Jack over here a
mr. Graham Stefan thank you for having
me and I made sure I had a troll a
little bit I have to throw a little bit
let me just say first off I'm not a fan
of Starbucks anymore they wrote Jerry
instead of Jeremy come six dollars for
this you can't spell my name
some scholars I'm letting you in love
almost something like that thanks 575
yeah it's that's insane it's it's a
vanilla latte for anyone it's not aware
20 cents this is stronger than that
they only give you that much coffee
the rest is ice and then the rest of it
is cream yeah and imagine if I invested
that six dollars and got just a 10% of
Terry missiles so anyway for those who
are not aware you run one of the largest
stock trading channels on YouTube yeah I
would propose a stock investing but
stock market investing yeah so financial
education my main channel and I had the
second channel financial education too
and yeah we just talk about stock market
investing all the time and honestly you
know I love it that's what I love to
talk about yeah but you didn't start off
with that
we started off with real estate
photography was it yeah so I started out
with a real estate photography
this internal zone like my
entrepreneurial journey yeah and then
for you I was 25 okay yeah 25 and I was
just like I was bored I didn't have that
many clients you know you like start a
business you know I'm that many
customers and then I was like I gotta do
something so I had this little GoPro
camera and I was like I'm gonna put this
on the tripod and start recording some
videos it was like super wide angle and
that got me on the YouTube journey and I
remember that I remember it's fun by the
way you're gonna hate this you go to
your channel and you know sort videos by
oldest it's like a hundred videos with
mmm like just one minute video like one
minute videos what it's a checking
account what are the savings account and
that's how you got started on YouTube
yep and I've always decided to keep
those videos up to like people can see
the journey I'm like you know where I
started cuz I remember looking when I
started youtube I remember like looking
at like past videos of big youtubers and
being like wow they were like you know
they were at this place and I always
hate it when like some of the big
youtubers would delete their old videos
cuz it's like it's like motivation it's
like wow they were they were nobody and
they grew following and it's like it's
amazing yeah they're not fun so so you
were doing real estate photography and
then YouTube for fun
YouTube yep okay you weren't making any
money youtube back then no the first
year pretty much I did I mean I made
hundreds of videos yeah that first year
didn't make hardly anything I think that
I think the first time I got a youtube
check was at least probably 10 months
into the my journey and that was
probably 200 videos and at that point so
yeah it was it was like in my wasting
time here like what's going on and then
finally I started click and I remember
that first like YouTube check which was
like like literally like a hundred bucks
or something it was like it was like all
money in the world cuz it was like whoa
I actually made money from YouTube
what you didn't want to do it for money
you wanted to do it just for fun
well I always knew you could make money
so I was like if we get to that place
like that's gonna be awesome
but you know if we don't we don't I'm
like it the worst case scenario is I put
out a ton of videos a ton of content and
it helps out hopefully people and just
understanding like basic financial stuff
and I was a little afraid to go stock
market even though that was always like
my main passion I was always kind of a
little afraid to go there cuz I didn't
know like what the laws were like were
you allowed
because when I started there weren't
like any big stopper to channels right
so it was like can I legally talk about
my opinion on Apple stock like is that
like allowed am I gonna get in trouble
for that like I really like had these
thoughts and so I was really afraid to
go there and I didn't start going there
until the end of that first year and
that's when my channel started take off
once I started getting into stock market
investing stocks I was buying everything
really started changed for me and I was
like this is perfect like this is
exactly what I want to do but you were
still doing real estate photography like
her I'm making the bulk of your money
real estate photography oh yeah real
estate marketing like videos for homes I
was doing like drone videos before like
drone videos were a thing there were
some high-end properties I mean this
2015/2016 like most most realtors were
not using drones to market at that time
other than maybe like LA and stuff but
out in Vegas it wasn't like a big thing
yet so I kind of like hopped on that
wave before like other people knew it
was a thing and that's how I like drove
that initial business people like well
you fly around a drone it was GG I just
came out with like the DJI phantom 3 and
yeah and now that's what actually helped
that business out and that's what paid
the bills and that's what got me through
to keep doing YouTube essentially
because I think if I honestly would have
started working a normal job again I
probably would quit yeah but you were
taking all that money Midwest putting in
the stock market at that time yeah well
paying bills one you know I had one of
my children at that time I just got
married so I was at that time with the
real estate I was mostly using that
money to pay bills fund the YouTube
business and then yeah try to invest a
little bit here and there
so mm-hmm and then when did you start
getting really heavy into the stock
market because this is what bring anyone
may be talking stocks so 2008-2009 when
I started researching stocks started
investing and I started investing
heavily once I started working at QT
which was we have to go back to like
2010 for that 2010-2011 and yeah that's
when I started really investing a lot as
far as YouTube you know I started really
talking more about stocks in about 2017
that's when I started feeling
comfortable to put myself out there and
that's a whole that's a whole other
thing there when you start talking about
stocks because stocks move up and down
every day mm-hmm
so you have to really have thick skin
because if also you talk about
I'm gonna buy you know Tesla stock today
in Tesla stock the next day goes down 3%
everybody's like oh you're so stupid you
should have waited to buy Tesla stock
yeah it's it's a tough I get so nervous
anytime they're off the video in the
software jack knows and tell them like
if monday is green if it's not green my
whole video of ruined really or i don't
get them out the same day because i know
if people watching the next day it's no
different happens so yeah there's the
video i've made i planned out full
videos like that you I've got like ready
to post but something changes like I
can't post anymore yeah yeah like all
this uh you know talk about stock market
collapse the next day the Dow goes up a
thousand points it's like oh so you
built your channel though on I'm just
very basic videos remember seeing them
back then because you and I it was you
started right before me yeah and we were
neck-and-neck
I'm watching you subscriber can you hit
fifty thousand before I think almost
anybody else did you were one of the
first job was to hit fifty thousand
subscribers yeah no that was a - Jan
yeah finance channels know and I know
you you know we spoke about this many
times you said like I was an inspiration
back there for you oh yeah and now I
look at you as an inspiration because
you've shown the whole space like what's
really capable of and I'm like you know
I I don't think I would be at the level
on that without you because you've
opened up my mind to what's possible on
you to like be explosions and thumbnails
[Music]
[Laughter]
like a monotone yeah nobody in all
seriousness who've been you've been a
huge like inspiration for me and I think
you know for anybody in the space just
realizing what's possible like it's not
just like a super niche thing you know
you look at the type of view counts you
pull in these are this is like big for
any YouTube to not just like oh it's big
for a finance space it is it's an
exciting time man for the whole space it
really is it's so exciting it is so so
you're doing now coming out from all of
that you're just doing YouTube full time
yummy you made the switch when did you
make the switch to decide
listen is my yeah that was the beginning
of 18 I think 2018 if I recall I was
starting to think toward them 2017 I was
like I was doing the real estate
marketing business and that at that time
was pretty much bringing in just as much
money as YouTube but the YouTube numbers
were increasing so dramatically that I
was starting to realize like the time I
was putting into attracting new real
estate marketing clients keeping those
ones that it just it was a really poor
ROI compared to what you know where I
was going with YouTube like it was clear
people wanted
like for instance I remember being on
this happens several times like on real
estate marketing jobs like doing videos
or photos or talking with you know
Realtors or whatever and something super
important happening in the market and
being out on a job taking pictures or
doing a video or whatever conversating
and just being like I need to be home
like recording this video right now yeah
and and I was just like this is crazy
like I am literally like not making a
wise financial decision by staying with
this and so I dropped the business you
know I talked a lot of people about it
and my mom she's like no don't let it go
no I just dropped it I was just kind of
like whatever I'll just let it go I sent
out a mass email all my customers and I
was like you know I mean I can subscribe
you know I know yeah I think I was still
good yeah it's funny I think I was still
a little embarrassed about YouTube so I
don't think I told them what I was doing
I you know cuz it's like it was like
that thing like because you know people
are gonna be like are you crazy we're
gonna drop a legitimate business over
here to do YouTube mm-hmm
you know and I think a lot of people
still don't understand like you know
this might be made on YouTube and social
media and all these things it's not just
like followers don't mean anything you
know
so yeah it's you I didn't I was
embarrassed when I started doing it I
really I have not like on my personal
facebook I would say is where I have
like all my friends from like high
school or a school that I never once
talked about why never once never told
them like either yeah so embarrassed I
was like what if someone clicks on my
video and there's like 10 dislikes on a
trip yeah yeah
so Barrett so never I totally sympathize
the same thing here I didn't even tell
my family most the time and I remember
back then I'd be embarrassed to like
record so I would wait for like my wife
to go to bed to like even record videos
or like if she was out or something like
that you know in like close the door and
like record a YouTube video cuz it's
like it's a weird thing so yeah I
remember that the whole stage and now
I'm like people like you know because
you know I have workers and different
people that you know come to the office
and they think like they got to get out
of the room I'm like dude it doesn't
matter like I can't I can't do that I
polar than they tell I tell my
girlfriend like you got to put on you
gotta close the door ya got to put on
those noise canceling headphones and I'm
gonna film walking around here mess up
what a talker and I supposed to repeat
the same thing over and over
yeah it's just embarrassed so now you're
just basically you're making YouTube
videos in trading stocks that's full
time right now yes like for you to make
money in the stock market right now ah
very easy yeah unfortunately I mean you
know this days you know recently where
I'm like you know it's like 50k 80k 100k
like it's been really easy to make money
lately I don't think this is gonna last
forever and I don't mean to jump ahead
you know cuz I know we're still talking
about YouTube jury and stuff like that
but right now you know the markets just
been hot man it's like the last two and
a half months it's been crazy it's just
been up alright you know straight line
down since December overall because I
know January so so your way positive way
positive yeah yeah way positive I mean
it's like you know you tribute that tail
uh-1 well a lot of different stocks have
helped me out but Tesla's a main one
okay I think I'm up over 300% s all
right now in the end of public count so
that one alone is like how many tests
assist you in that account 150 I think
in total I don't know the exact numbers
probably around 300 so gotcha now you
have the public account that's the one
that I see you post all the time on is
yeah the public account just remember
one hit like threesome yeah
how much is in the bus I think over 600
yeah 600,000 do you contribute regularly
to that account or is that purely just
you're growing it with stuff I'd
contribute to it when the markets down
big or there's a you know a specific
opportunity in the market that's huge
where I'm like I got a funnel money in
unfortunately since the markets been
going up I've hardly funneled any money
in so the gains late they had just been
coming from every stock pretty much I
own in that account going up I mean heck
even Carnival Cruise Lines been going up
lately I mean that one bottomed out at
like 8:00 and I think it's over 20 now
yeah you know so it's been incredible
yeah the gating the gains have been
insane the last few months you have the
public key and in what's the private
account how do we so I it's what's in
that yeah so I private accounts they
pretty much mirror the same stocks like
if I oh if I buy a stock in the public
account I'd probably buy it in my
private accounts as well
now how impressive though is a private
guy because I don't even know it's got
to be over a million you know I would
have I would tell you but I would have
to own your YouTube channel after that
me over a million five if you give me
the Graham Steffen show I'll show you
what's in it don't you don't you show
it's in the private again to the people
knowing the members you know you donate
but they can see every position in the
public count every single move I make
any time I buy sell share and they know
about any move I make before I even make
it so I'm like hey guys I'm gonna
probably buy this stock tomorrow or oh
no so it's done really funny what's on
you do this would be sneaky ever you do
in the public account you buy everything
yeah in the private account you're short
Wow there's only get to say wow that
would be a very unprofitable endeavor
considering like the majority my stocks
are up but yeah it's really just just
that's that's your investment portfolio
at this day you know I have multiple
private accounts too I have my main
private account why it's so private
accounts well I was to see like because
of you guys for the stock market group
the public account so they know this is
public to you you could see every single
move I make in that account by cell
everything's documented kospi says you
get to see a little screenshots of the
account
where's private account it's just more
for like privacy like I'm kind of weird
about privacy like I like I like you
know you don't like people knowing like
your net worth like I don't I don't
share really anything about my family
like you you know you don't see my kids
and my videos or even on Instagram for
the most part and that's where you
likely see stuff I don't share my wife I
I believe like although I'm out there
I still like have some boundaries with
privacy and you know I I understand like
a lot of people in social media they
don't care they're like just post
everything for me I'm just like this
boundaries I said I'm like I'm not
willing to go that far why why why is
that account off-limits where is the
other one the other one how I started
that was basically so everybody in the
private group could see me build an
account yeah like how I how I build a
portfolio and how I make moves how I
actually like buy-and-hold like I'm not
just like trading in and out of these
stocks every day and so it's like it was
a new account when I started like how
much was in it like a couple thousand
bucks 600 thousand six hundred thousand
you could buy yeah how much I put in
since six hundred thousand I don't know
because we're up like 200k right now in
paper profits but also we took profits
in 18 we took profits in 19 I think in
main cook 30 I want to say like 30k in
profits I came home to a specific number
so it's hard to you know I would say at
least half the money in there was
deposited though sorry about a hundred
percent in three years I would say so
yeah I mean fidelity calculates us at I
can pull it up right now the reason you
hide it is just to hide your network
from people you don't want people
knowing I think it's more fun that way
honestly I think it's more fun I do my
guess is there's got to be close to one
and a half 30 million that's your guess
yeah I'm gonna guess you know what so
any s two million dollars so the public
counts at 584 right now and it looks
like on Friday we made five thousand
four hundred eleven dollars one year
ready to return seventy four point five
eight percent so we've done pretty good
but the huge dip Taurus up they look at
that yeah down remove and then look at
how it's just gone you know crazy sins
oh but yeah that's like a lot by Tesla
because well increase that much yeah
yeah I mean Tesla's up you know over
300% in that account
it's let me look at Tesla yeah three
hundred three hundred eleven percent
we're up one hundred six thousand while
we're talking about Tesla is it too late
to invest in Tesla oh that's a tough one
you know I gotta say if you're a
long-term investor I don't think it's
too late because I you know I personally
believe is gonna be a two three thousand
dollar stock in the future if I know
over the next five years or so but at
the same time if you're if you're trying
to do a short-term move around it I just
don't think it's a great stock to do it
around it's too volatile it's almost
like it's one of those stocks that very
few come along kind of like an Amazon an
apple of Google where you just buy it
and you just hold it man you just throw
it in the filing cabinet you try not to
look at the stock price it's good you
know if it's at five hundred a year from
now or two thousand you try not to make
judgments off that it's one of those you
just buy and you forget about it I think
a lot of people think the same thing
that like Tesla is gonna be the next you
know Amazon or whatever and they're all
piling into it now with that expectation
don't you think that's maybe influence
the price because yeah part of me looks
at the cloud coming in like it was maybe
like four or five hundred bucks yeah but
but you but it might never get there
because people just have so much faith
in the company that it's never going to
hit what it's I think I'm at valued at
most you know with these special
opportunities they really just trade you
know way ahead of themselves like years
in advance
Amazon's done that since the beginning
of time you know since when that
wouldn't went public in the 90s it's
always traded way ahead of the market
because a lot of investors just look at
and they're like it's just the future
and obviously it's the now as well when
it comes to Amazon and that's why that
one's out of 1.3 trillion dollar market
cap right now Amazon because well if
you're trying to base Amazon off of what
they're doing today there's no way one
point three trillion dollar valuation
makes sense for Amazon today but when
you base it off of what they're doing in
five years it might be a steal so in
that and that goes for a lot of these
great companies you know there was
there's been a lot of times where Apple
been weighed overvalued and there's been
times where it's been undervalued so you
know sometimes these long-term
investments you have to throw it in the
filing cabinet it's been the hard part
with me with stocks over real estate
because real estate I feel like there's
a very definitive range of value and
it's very easy to buy it purposely
undervalue where it stops it's like this
is what it's trading at and you have no
clue if it's ever gonna go down yeah
this continually get excited about it
yeah yeah no I totally understand that I
mean I feel like some of these stocks
like a Tesla you have to view it in the
in the sense of of buying a real estate
property whereas if you buy a real
estate property across the street from
you today you're not thinking about all
I gotta sell out if it goes up you know
one percent tomorrow or something like
that
you're you're focused on what does that
property gonna generate me over you know
year and year out for the next number of
years and so I feel like some of these a
lot of stocks in general I should put it
that way you just got to kind of view
the same way like what is this business
gonna likely do over the next 5-10 years
what am I gonna likely see what's the
downside risk what's kind of worst-case
scenario with this and I think you got
to view it very similar to real estate
rather than view it as these arbitrary
numbers that are jumping around each day
mm-hmm so is that why you call it
investing rather than trading 100
percent you yeah you come out of that
yeah because trading it's really a
mentality up gotta get in gotta get out
and got it all right I'm this get boom
boom boom boom and you're making moves
all over the place whereas investing
it's more like I've looked into this
asset I fully understand a very high
level and I understand the valuation and
I likely understand where it's going
over the next five ten years because
I've researched is so in-depth that I
understand on a level that the CEO would
understand it or somebody high up in the
company and I make it a wise investment
decision and so you invest in it like a
real estate investment property but it's
with the stock of a company how do you
learn how to do that
a lot of you know where you go do
research in Jeremy's a private stock
market group ok no no but in all
seriousness you know how I learned
initially was watching warren buffett
youtube interviews on Popeye yeah on
YouTube I would go to the computer lab
at the community college and you know
this is this is back an old school
YouTube days at this point this is like
we're talking 2008-2009 even to 2010
and I was just like Warren Buffett
interview and just watch interview after
interview and throughout watching those
interviews and you know a lot of it
could be wasted times they talk about
what's going on market right now but in
a lot of those interviews he would go
into his investment process and you know
if there's an hour-long interview you're
going to get 10 minutes probably in
there that's really really valuable in
that 10 minutes was worth watching a
full hour and so that's how I learned a
lot I you know read a few books but the
books didn't really help me it was those
Warren Buffett interviews and then
getting in the market
I think the biggest Warren Buffett's
investment strategies are still affected
I always go back to ask that yeah so I
think they're not as if I think his
principles are oh yeah you know
specifically what he's looking looking
for in stocks in a company yes but the
unfortunate thing for Warren Buffett is
I think he kind of aged out of the
market whereas he doesn't invest in tech
stocks he you know chooses not to do
that and he's in it it's like so many
companies or tech now I mean even you
know yeah it goes against what you were
saying is if they're trading years ahead
of where they actually are and if Warren
Buffett's all about value investing
today yeah tech stocks don't fit that
because they're valued higher sometimes
sometimes you can get tech tech stocks
for a very good value dome an example is
you know company about a few years ago
named cirrus logic another company I
bought with Sky work solutions to that
have done me amazing tech stocks their
semiconductors they make most of the
like chips that go into your iPhone or a
Samsung or whatever smartphones and
those are tech stocks but they were
trading that really attractive values
they were trading at four p's of when I
bought them I think like 12 to 15 range
which is incredibly low for the stock
market so it's not impossible to find
good values in tech sometimes like a
Tesla at Amazon a Shopify is a whole
other level that one trades it like a
5000 Ford P or some insane number you
know those ones I can I could really
fully understand Warren Buffett saying
maybe not those ones but there's a whole
other gamut so I you know like anything
in life I think you just kind of age you
out one day will age out at YouTube I'm
sure and you know it's just it's like at
that in every industry you just kind of
you age out you don't understand the new
concepts and new ways of selling I mean
you you came from real estate industry
I'm sure there's older Realtors that
back in their day they were moving
properties like crazy and then new
things changed social media claims in
all Senate was like whoa this person
they don't just they don't get how to
sell properties in 2020 they were trying
to still sell in the 2000 wave so yeah
what would you say are the the best
principles you learned if you're willing
to disclose the best principles I
learned looking at the fundamental
business and focusing on that first
don't worry about stock price don't
worry about valuation don't even worry
about the financials at first really
look into the company what is this
company doing view it on a very specific
wave where you're trying to you know
what does this microphone company do how
do they make money who are their
competitors that's the way you want to
do it that's that's the most important
thing and making sure you understand you
have a circle of confidence around that
from there then you can go into
valuations then you can go into the
financials the income statements balance
sheets cash flows all those sorts of
things you can go into conference calls
but you've got to understand the
business first where a lot of people get
into trouble is they'll buy a stock
because they heard about this stock and
I call I gotta buy this and it's like
they may not even understand the
business on a fundamental level it's so
key it is so key it's the most important
thing so so on the topic in its stocks
what do you think it hurts hurts that's
a ridiculous situation so hurts you have
a company that's filing bankruptcy you
have the stock should be going a zero
like when a company announces their
they're gonna go bankrupt like there
should be going to zero the shareholders
usually get nothing if there's anything
the you know whoever gave them debt gets
the money first then if there's any
money after that's bonds and so the
shareholders should have got nothing in
this way deal yeah lawyers yeah
everybody makes money except really a
shareholders and then the stock cop
bought ups so crazy why why did people
buy the stock I don't know I was
shorting it it wasn't like a short push
yeah so there was a there was a lot of
people that were shorting and
understanding it's likely going to zero
and then on top of that you had this
whole wave of people start bidding it up
and because if it got to be a hot stock
more and more people start buying it
which caused more and more
short-covering which if you're going to
cover your shares you've got to buy the
underlying shares back so if you have a
hundred shares short and you get let's
say you know called on it where your
brokerage says hey you gotta you gotta
buy that you
got to cover your short position then
you've got to buy a hundred shares so
that makes another buyer in the market
anyway that's happening a mass you get
to stock to go up in the amazing thing
about this story is it's one of only
things I've ever seen the stock market
like this they're actually gonna get to
raise money because the stocks gone up
so much it outside until they
potentially not go bankrupt I've never
seen like this billion dollars yeah
I've honestly never seen you know you
couldn't make this stuff up like it's
incredible when a company like literally
ninety-nine out of a hundred times
company says they're going bankrupt the
starts going to zero there's no way of
saving it well I remember JCPenney and I
was actually but this is after they
filed for bankruptcy and I thought you
know what it's just like how I would
worse gonna get from here I really have
that mind so I didn't do it but I was
saying like how do you know just brand
in there yeah it can't get any worse
maybe you get lucky yeah maybe that's
that's what would an insurer enough it
like tripled in price right afterwards
I'm like I should have done it if I
bought into u3 selling
oh it's gosh I didn't do it but I think
that's the mentality wouldn't Hertz file
bankruptcy I figured I was like it's
down so much and it used to be this big
stock and now it's down here it's like a
little bit yeah no I know there
certainly is a group of traders out
there that like to try to play these
type of claims and get in and out and
there's nothing wrong with it but from
my perspective of looking at it from an
investment perspective it's just not an
activity I can get into because this
doesn't make any sense like if you're
buying into a failing business model
business models gonna fail you know what
I mean like it's just it's just when
does it fail as a fail this year does it
feel next year does a Fiat fail in three
years from now you just know it's gonna
go bad it's no different than imagine
you know there were people in the you
know the city I live in Vegas right
there are people in the housing boom
rate that were buying properties and
selling them the next day and making
like ten thousand twenty thousand
dollars because it was sad and saying
they would be lines to buy the condo in
Vegas like I've had you know Realtors
tell me this before and like lines to
buy condo people just buy it with no
money down
flip it the next day for like 10 20
profit or so craziness right and it's
the same thing in stock market it
happens all the time you have this group
of people that are going to try to
speculate and sometimes they can get
lucky and make some very short-term
money but at the end of the day it's not
a long-term investment model this is not
I mean look you can look at anybody you
really respect an investing category
who's ever achieved a huge level six
success none of them got there from
trying to get in and out of Hertz and
you see tiny stock it doesn't work over
the long term it's more of a gamblers
mentalities Hertz go bankrupt what was
so bad about her versus like enterprise
I haven't looked at the company on that
high of a level I'm guessing it's
probably balance she related they
probably had a bad balance sheet
roni Rona comes out of nowhere knocks
them for a loop and all some they're
stuck in a situation where like no
money's coming in oh we got all this
debt payments I'm assuming that's what's
happening there they probably have a
bunch of debt payments no money coming
in what are you gonna do you're gonna
probably go bankrupt so and they already
have
fundamentals issues there because they
have so many competitors on the come-up
right now that are apps where you can
rent cars Sarah
Turo you know that's that's just one
example right and then you have on top
of that uber and lyft and people are
like I don't even need a rent-a-car if
I'm gonna go visit LA I'm just gonna
goober around lifter man why do I want
to rent a car like it would be just
simpler if I do this scooters you know
exist the whole game has changed for
Hertz over the past ten years really and
it's gone for the wars speaking of uber
I saw California now classify some uber
drivers as employees yeah
that is gonna be interesting a yeah
that's gonna be interesting to see how
that plays out what I think's gonna
happen applauding up to make more
full-time drivers where they do have
benefits and everything but they have to
drive specific albers and for you know
some of you were drivers that's gonna be
great they want to you know set schedule
but for a lot of them actually probably
the majority of them they like to
control it you know so I'm not I'm not
sure it you know for some people it's
gonna be better for some people's gonna
be war I think for 90% of people is
gonna be worse yeah I agree I think is
meant to be a job you can be like hey
eight o'clock yeah plans got canceled
you're on and let me work two hours and
then stop right yep make a little model
let me let me go all night
yep what I think is gonna happen because
one of the things that I've read is it
the reason they classified the these
drivers as employees is because uber is
the one that sets the price and so these
people don't even though they're
independent contractors they can't set
their own rates and is it what I would
like to see that I think we would
greatly benefit over is that you know I
think within reason the driver can set
their own rates that would reintroduce
your interest and get you know a place
the only thing is like when you go on
Oberon you're like within a seconds like
oh how much that fright gonna have to
wait for people to bid uh-huh do you
think prices would go up or down for the
for the for the riders I think we'll
find a middle ground I don't know I
think the same initially they'll get bit
bit down but during certain peak hours
but you know the price would get bit up
the other thing now I'm just thinking
now is that if that happens you'll get
some uber doors like purposely waiting
to put in their big they could wait a
little bit longer bid it up so that
could be a consideration or if they're
in a town with like you know almost no
didn't yeah one person is there then you
know like that person you were the one
that was negotiating yeah but it would
be interesting you had the drivers big
their own rates because that they do
with a lot of shipping um like frite or
dothis they'll bid it around don't you
have the option to go and pick the
lowest bidder oh yeah I think trucking
industry you know to a certain extent
yeah I I don't see that working because
it's too it's too at a micro level I
think consumers will start to hate uber
then you get into what what happens if
lyft drivers are undercutting the uber
driver you know more price fix you guys
is the same thing gonna happen to lift
Vincent to happen to who were more
likely
why yeah if it hasn't having a lift I
think the industry's just got so big now
I think the government's just looking
out and they're like we don't want you
guys independent contractors I think
that why what's the bit why why would
they do that tax reasons mainly you know
if you're an employee the employer has
to take out taxes it's more professional
on that level versus independent
contractors they have to pay their own
taxes and I think the government's
probably not getting nearly as much
money so they're thinking all these
independent contractors are cheating the
tax system are not making their fair
share yeah I don't know about all of
them but they probably feel like it's a
big enough number and they probably
don't like the example were setting in
terms of having so many independent
contractors versus employees because the
fact is it is much more expensive for
from a company standpoint to have
employees versus having a bunch in yeah
you have to double the Association
yes exactly and and so I think I think
government at the end the day they want
to make an example of these these
industries before they get too enormous
I say let's make an example of them now
and let's get this done you know I think
that's at the end of the day that's the
biggest thing mm-hmm
okay well that's a shame yeah so wait oh
so would you invest in Hoover well I
love Eber I sold out a stock recently
for a nice profit
the main issue for uber is gonna be how
fast is rideshare comeback you know we
don't really know how that's gonna shake
you out with this whole you know roni
roni situation you know shut down
worldwide economies you know uber eats
is doing amazing right now like that
business is doing amazing anything food
delivery wise like it this is a perfect
scenario for that right your business it
couldn't get worse because travels just
shut down you know I think I think I
heard something like San Francisco might
shut down for three weeks or something
like that no I've heard something about
that not a hundred percent to confirm
but yeah I think my wife mentioned
something about San Francisco might
close down for three weeks and you know
I have no clue that's true or not once
again well we'll see I'm sure Graham's
fact-checking it right now but uh you
know when you just look at that and just
the lack of mobility right now it's it's
definitely a big risk for Oberer you
know because they're right cher business
is their biggest business so does the
illness really affect your investing
strategy like has it
it changed like a lot of your
speculations and stuff you're talking
about the Rona yeah uh you know not
really too much I mean other than
industries that has fundamentally
changed for instance one of my positions
a Carnival Cruise Line like it's
fundamentally really changed the
business model for the worse like that
was an amazing very profitable business
but because cruising's been shut down
it's just it's in a horrible place right
now and we don't know how long that will
continue so if it's changed it
fundamentally yes yeah you still use the
same principles across the board or at
essentially those haven't changed yeah
no it hasn't changed and I and I try not
to put too much emphasis in the whole
Rona situation because this this is a
100-year thing right and so you can't
make every judgment what did you find
anything about the San Francisco
situation you're not they're not okay
top it was a rumor though right or
saying oh you're talking about the
reopening plans oh so there's still
there's still so much shutdown okay I'm
reopening okay cuz I think they said the
source was TMZ and I said well that does
sound credible TMZ has actually been a
really credible name TMZ is one of the
most accurate in terms of the
information they portray more than news
outlets you TMZ is like so precise of
their information and sometimes they get
stories before everybody else I have so
many people I feel like infiltrates
everybody you could possibly imagine
that do leaking information and I'm sure
that's why they go to TMZ I'm just
guessing I still haven't figured out how
t MZ makes all their money is it from
that the show they have on channel 2
I've watched I haven't watched that show
ages yeah YouTube channel 11
right yeah yeah what a career that guy
has had yes series in a multi-decade
long career going from what was it he
was an attorney and he's an attorney and
he would comment on cases yeah and he
went from that to then TMZ why I bet you
if he had waited a little like his
career blossomed a little later I bet
she would have done more full in on
YouTube
rather than created a channel you know I
bet you he would have started YouTube
joins me in five Perez
remember that perez hilton's hill to
that was to act like 2004-2005 okay as
Hilton had a blog that he would just
talk trash about celebrities on it oh it
was so big and he's known as press oh
wow yeah I want to know no that's
interesting enough fact the government
loves money man eat guys general oh yeah
yeah you know what I mean
it's like a guy generates a lot of money
I mean he got I think he released a
music video they got 63 million gaps in
a day but you know what you know it's
way easier I can spin that around that's
good for his career his fro Isle for
that like two months everyone was
talking about him yeah oh yeah he was
just even though you're not in the
hip-hop community like people were
mention he just calls that I ever know
when he when he actually released his
record like everyone's nickimja no yeah
yeah I'm not a fan of music but like I
don't know maybe behind it all he's a
really really really smart there's no
way no way I saw the most absurd news
article when he was in jail and it was
from like his lawyer and it was like
Takashi six nine is request requesting
to be released from prison because he's
scared he'll get that and that was like
that was like an argument that he was
using he's like man I can't get
coronavirus like like I gotta get out of
here and like that was a legit article
it was like posted multiple times on
many different like sites he was scared
of it I love a lot of these people I
really believe they're so smart being
yes means and it's just it's a I accept
that yeah if you understand how to get
attention it's no different than the
Kardashians like you know Kardashian's
also and they stop you don't have it as
much interest also you did some
ridiculous thing you hear about the
Kardashians and then all sudden
everybody's like viewing their profiles
and watching Keeping Up with the
Kardashians again they understand how to
keep in the spotlight you know I think
that the cops ain't ain't figured it out
here's it here's another youtuber that
I've met with I'll tell you guys out but
you would see their videos you'd be like
through their idiots
mmm-hmm but separate from that they know
did that's like they got a play to that
because that's that you know that's
their audience and behind the scenes are
so smart and they're making like
hundreds of thousand dollars a month in
profit and from the looks of it you
would think like these people are so
stupid
but anyway Paris Hilton I think was the
originator of this whole movement yeah
cuz Paris Hilton sheep she's a you know
believe it or not she's actually super
smart and I actually talks really
intelligent
if you've ever like talked her outside
of that show they got famous off them
which was her and I think it was was it
Lindsay Lohan or who was the other
person that I can't remember always
hitting Nicole something oh yeah yeah oh
I can't remember the name of the simple
life the simple life McGinnis Hilton and
Nicole Richie
yes and you know they would act like oh
so dumb I uh you know a trainee Jonathan
yes that [ __ ] and they got so much
attention and people would tune in
whether they loved them or they hated
them they would tune in when they got
views and then if I recall I think Kim
Kardashian was like an intern or
something underneath Paris Hilton and
then she understood how to kind of like
gain leverage whether you know it's
people just getting people talking about
you get it out there and then obviously
the whole Kardashian family built and
then you got so many people you know you
know we go back to the coffee 6-9 I
think he just realizes there's so much
you know it doesn't matter whether
people are talking pause they're bad
about you as long as they're talking
about you Floyd Mayweather the boxer you
know how do you become the richest boxer
and get like two hundred million dollars
a fight because everybody want to see
him lose maybe this is the time a was
gonna lose let me buy the hundred dollar
pay-per-view and then he would win but
you know it's just like people just want
to be in a play a see officially he's
officially retired but yeah but they
always say that I always come at a
return man he was running miles of the
day like you know I don't I don't know
if any of your tired boxer just runs
miles to run miles he might come out I
wouldn't be surprised to him fight
McGregor again gosh
yeah there's a hundred million up there
yeah Anthony oh Anthony had a big on
Mayweather last few times disease never
lost
every single time he keeps upping his
bet boom and you have my last game
taking me like 60 grand
okay I went to him on him batting on
Mayweather cuz he's like young guys
never lost there's no way yeah yeah yeah
the entire meant to do one fight and
then lose yeah no way to MMA yes imagine
a you know with a guy like that 50 you
know imagine if you started betting with
him just like a hundred dollars his very
first fight in like the 90s and then you
just you never sell out every time you
just put whatever you made into the next
one the next one the next so you just
like what is that if you start with a
hundred dollars compounded by 50 well
you would make so the prom' is above the
threshold yeah once he got to certain
you have more money than that exists
yeah so a problem is like even though
right yeah it's not a yellow one even if
you bet a million on them in some of
those fights you might only profit 100k
because they put the odds you know so
far against the other guy I bet you
that's more than like our GDP yeah you
would be America at that point
so you're saying massively in debt so
I'm only thirty into it yeah so one
point one to 59
so with 17 zeros you own the world
dollars yeah you doubled a hundred odd
that would be like a quintillion oh gosh
that's the crazy number well fun fact of
the day yeah just beyond beyond honestly
the 15th time he's won wouldn't
[Laughter]
as much money in circulation for your
back to know we'll see if he plays again
that's a sign yeah loses that's a
one-time time for him to say like let's
say it's a stage like yeah I wasn't in
my prime
yelling more I think he would rather go
out undefeated are you down to put a
month YouTube salary down on them if he
ever fights it yet no would you do two
weeks half a month you could make
interesting content I will say that
realistically I would probably I feel
comfortable at 20 grand what are the
ratios now what's the payout uh Walden
probably depend on who we fight but I
would say he would be Alisa Tendo in
favor so um the ones yeah so hundred
dollars you bet you win ten dollars I
would say yeah you're really gonna do
that for two grand but it would be
everybody else so what is it like living
in Vegas living in Vegas man it's
amazing I love it you know I've lived
three place in my life Arizona is where
I grew up Phoenix Arizona
then we moved out to Charlotte North
Carolina for a few years and Charlotte
was fine it's just I didn't really like
the East Coast and then I yeah I lived
in lived in Vegas since 2015 and loved
it and absolutely loved it so be closer
the west coast again and taxes and I
just kind of like the vibe of Vegas you
know being 24/7 and things like that and
also just kind of I feel like there's an
entrepreneurial like vibe out there also
so but taxes have big reason ah it's
really the only place you can be on this
part of like the west coast where you
can still have no taxes because I think
it's at
think of Seattle right also is it
Seattle that also has no taxes I know
there's like yeah de Florida Texas
no no state taxes and yeah so I was just
like looked at the options out there and
I was like all I want to be close to a
West Coast get it hey guess that's
that's a play you know Nevada so yeah I
love it I love it it is great and then
it's fun you know only people come out
you know friends or family
everyone's go strip of course you gamble
not really unless I'm with Graham that's
the only person I will do it with what
do you think you'll have to come with us
today what do you what do you what do
you guys play you play blackjack right
like blackjack Bach Ron crafts
yeah perhaps I think is the most fun
because you get everybody around the
table yeah you know throw the dice I'd
love to see I'd love to see you guys
play craps and and Graham's girlfriend
could not be named Graham's girlfriend
always goes on a hot streak oh she went
on a roll when she gets the table using
everyone just like taking out there
hundreds through Anthony was just like
takes like wads like ten thousand
dollars are you kidding me he's it's a
blast to watch but but yeah but but they
see her come up the table and she has no
clue what she's doing and she's like
dude and oh people love it so there's a
superstition when someone comes to the
table a woman who doesn't know what
she's doing
you bet heavy because she's just gonna
keep rolling that the winning numbers so
any time like like someone like that
comes a table you'll see all these guys
just like you know does she know how to
wait like how the game works the game
and that's I think the good thing behind
you is because she doesn't know like if
she knows don't roll a seven guess she's
gonna roll a seven right she's like what
do i did just roll it and hit the back
of the thing okay and just that it's
like it's like yeah the hard six they'll
call it because it'll be two threes and
it was like okay okay hard six we're
sisters
there so roll it again it's a hard six
and people lose their minds just hit the
roll the same thing again and
everyone had their money on that they
making a lot of money or she she's role
for like 10 minutes yeah encore yeah
yeah something like that when people
were making thousands of dollars on this
and then some dude afterwards yeah never
moaning like 50 bucks yeah something
like that because the guy needs so much
money from her role he's like you know
thank you gave her money yeah the most
embarrassing thing about that all is I
lost money I was the only person at this
table that was like loaded with people
everybody's making so much money Graham
like for extra five X's money in a
matter of like 30 minutes I lost money
I'm like it was incredible cuz I was
betting on a field everybody else was
just playing like normal pass line of
stuff and maybe like backing it I'm
playing field I was the only like in and
all like the the dealers and whatnot
they looking at me and or they're like
oh you need to be colored up and then
they're like no he can't be colored up
he lost like they are all like running a
joke I'm like oh my gosh
how could I do the only person that lost
so that's another thing is that after a
really good role that's gone on for like
five or ten minutes you do what's called
coloring up which just means you take
all of your chips and you get the
highest denomination ship so you could
take all your $25 chips and hundred
dollar chips and you can trade them in
for like $1,000 chips or whatever so
when you go on a big roll like that the
chances of that happening again people
like listen I already did so well I'm
just gonna leave yeah so that's what
that's what I do so any time you get a
roll like that you're done no usually
that's a signal if you're done for the
night you go back the next day but yeah
every single time I go with Jeremy you
lose I know every time I'm like how it
was a single game there's too much to
lose here Jeremy do trust me this is not
a winning game you're not allowed to win
it's why don't trade yeah exactly it's
all just yelling yeah exactly I'm just
like no this is not for me so what about
Graham does he does he win or lose he
usually wins III I mean we've been out I
don't know how many times it's quite a
few and I don't know if I've ever seen
loose
I don't know who's thirty percent of
them I win seventy percent of the time I
don't know if I have legitimized yeah
I'll be honest I may be it's happened I
don't remember it so Kevin is fun to
play with me Kevin's crazy yeah yeah
because y'all just keep he'll be doubles
down he just goes right back it's more
money couples down yeah
he's one of those guys yeah and you like
at the roulette table you guys
eventually who wet yeah if you've been
right exactly you bet 40 you lose II bet
80 you lose it you bet you know 160
he'll just keep it eventually chances
are he'll hit one of those make all this
money back and he's like okay I could
start over again haha yeah go and relax
one color it wins he puts you know the
initial money plus the profit on it
again it wins again he does it again and
then finally like he'll end up losing
eventually but it's like dude the number
is I getting big now you know he's fine
he's doing a play with because he's
chatting up everybody
you know she wears Fedora no does it so
what's a does he wear that actually like
he's worn it out a few times is it's
cool and stylish no did you take it from
my white hat or what'd you take the idea
from there I haven't seen it because you
know I usually wear that way hat oh I
sighs yeah holy smokes ain't no joke is
what so the Holy Smoke is this ain't no
joke is it I don't know when exactly
started I might have been a year ago two
years ago but it was sometimes big video
topic and I got a bunch of comments
right away that they loved it and so now
if there's ever like big news I have
delete him with always hate milk Joker's
and most of time be like well guys here
today buh buh buh but you know if it's a
big video holy smokers this ain't no
joke
and that one is reserved for only the
big videos it has to be something Tesla
had to hit thousand dollars or something
in a day like something crazy had it
happen but uh yeah I know that's a fun
one but yeah I come up with so many
different nicknames for stocks like I
have cruzi doozy fizzy get dizzy Tesla
my Isla oh gosh yeah there's a lot of
like little nicknames do it
mini jim cramer oh gosh you need one of
those cymbals value something like that
when the witness stock hits a thousand
yeah when you're up 10% you hit
something
dude the amount of comments I've seen
over the past couple years where it's
like CNBC should hire you when Jim Jim
Cramer's retires not oh no I don't think
so
CNBC says like here's two million
dollars a year and you just got to make
you know you got it two videos a day my
business I don't know you know what's
amazing is you have a relationship with
CNBC and somehow I don't I'm the stock
guy and yet we don't communicate at all
I've never talked to CNBC
they never talked to me you know they
might not like me I might not like why
is because you haven't shared really
anything personal it's just okay yeah if
you start showing your family a little
bit more of a personal side it builds a
connection maybe I could ya know that
could but uh dad I don't know if I could
ever do that man would you would you do
a millennial money video I millennial my
video wow you would be a fun millennium
oh shoot I'd be tempted to I mean I've
seen what Graham has done it'd be hard
to turn do you want my baby yes I'll
reach out to them because they know it's
gonna be a big deal I think I think I
would have to I'd be honest I think I
would you'll do it I think I would do it
I think I would do it yeah I think I
have to do it I don't think I could
think as well as offers that you just
can't turn down okay yeah I think I'd
have to do it so just see you know they
would they like they went through
everything I mean they always they were
more particular than an underwriter
getting a loan believe me would ya Wow I
gave him a list of like like here are
the things and I told them like what my
payments are and they're like even my
Tesla team the way we want to see a
statement showing that like how much
your payment actually is and like what
you know what what you owe on it I would
100% love to do this because I literally
don't even know how much money I spend a
month I have no clue I was asked if we
could do some sort of mild budget
breakdown for you yeah I mean I I don't
know what we spend it could be my wife
probably knows it's probably 20,000
30,000 and monthly expenses I am you
know
wait what kind of expenses everything
well you I don't know maybe it's not
that much whoa business business
expenses so it's like do you subtract
business expenses from among the
expenses so I don't know but I mean we
have the mortgage but then we're gonna
have another mortgage in Arizona come in
then we got another mortgage in Vegas
coming mortgage that one's uh we just
got refinance and that one's only like
2,800 now it's not bad yeah no that
one's really affordable but then we're
gonna have an Arizona mortgage come and
that would be like another mm that's
coming this fall then we're gonna have
the new Vegas property you know that's
gonna be I don't know that's really you
know that's one's like gonna be probably
like 1.5 so let's say we put 20% down so
that might be like five six thousand a
month I would assume so we have a Model
X that's a thousand a month we have a
model three that's six hundred a month I
think and then we have just a lot of
other expenses man I like a lot of like
those little expenses where it's like
100 200 300 here and it just starts
adding up adding up so yeah yeah what
about food budget food budgets insane
it's got to be ridiculous so we have
five people that live in my house you
know obviously me my wife my two kids
and then my brother-in-law and we spend
so we spent a lot because then we go out
to dinners sometimes two and drop 100
200 bucks like we just went out the
other night and that was I don't know
what I end up spending that might be
done like 120 yeah I love to go out and
a lot of times when I go out I go to
nice places so yeah it's expensive
tastes like at least you've been like
school here gram dispraise there's a
subway across the street you're like Oh
Jeremy I'm sorry I'm not feeling so good
actually tonight
yeah yeah 20 minutes ago I was feeling
so good but ever since you sent that
last ten or something yeah I don't know
what the number is but know that I think
I'll be doing I would do it me I'll
reach out I'll do it okay I'll do it we
should build a connection of some kind
you know I feel like me being you know a
person in the stock market investing
space and CNBC always focused most on
stock market it's like it makes sense
for us to have some sort of relationship
even if it's not a deal one what you're
gonna get though inevitably because I
started getting a little bit of this but
Graham you make more money from YouTube
oh yeah real estate of course you know
what I try to explain to people is that
like YouTube is full time like yeah like
60 hours of me hours a week sometimes
real estate is passive like you got that
they're working 60 hours a week to
something that's passive yeah you'll
give you the new Jimmy make more YouTube
and stocks honestly I get I get that
alia I get comments like that you know
it's usually like a hate comment like oh
you make so much from YouTube and it's
like you know I I make maybe 60 K a
month from YouTube 50 to 60 let's say
okay in one trading day my accounts in
total will be likely if it's a volatile
day on the market decent volatile and I
like crazy will be up or down 50 60 K so
whatever I'm making a month from YouTube
and that's before business expenses and
all the sorts of things my accounts
alone will move likely that big in a day
I think somebody left a comment like
that the day and I usually don't even
reply to comments but because I was
smashing the thumbs up because I did
this day yeah yeah and I smash the
thumbs up for you I think the heart tip
yeah and yeah somebody was like you know
I saw it and it was like oh you make so
much I was like dude like you realize my
counts that day moved more than what I
make an entire month but yeah it's but
it's like it is at the end of day that's
what we do like you know we could be
focused on a lot of different businesses
doing a lot of different things it just
happens to be what we do you know for
you know business so now sometimes I
even think you know taken in a deeper
level sometimes I think if I'm like I
could actually be making way more money
if I
focus on doing something else and maybe
YouTube is actually holding me back from
doing something like way bigger I have
those type of thoughts sometimes where
I'm like you just don't really know what
I don't know you know I don't even think
about what else I could be doing because
I'm so focused on YouTube all the time
and what am I gonna make for an
interesting video and how am I going to
present this and so sometimes those
thoughts cross by my head I'm like what
if there's this big business opportunity
that I'm not even spending any time
thinking on because I'm so focused on
how I'm gonna get a hundred thousand
views on this video today and so there's
even that that that side of me that's
like you know because I'm constantly
looking at a company so I'm constantly
thinking about business I love talking
business with with people I mean usually
you know when you and I have one-on-one
conversations we always end up talking
about YouTube business and things like
that this is what I enjoy doing and so
it's like if I didn't put in so much
time to YouTube maybe there's this other
thing that I'd be a billionaire already
or you never really know you know is so
you know oh well so but those comments
are funny where it's like well you make
such-and-such it's like and the funny
thing is you know I don't think like
we're underpaid I feel like the amount
of attention and time we get compared to
like some of these actresses and actors
that you know we don't even have to
speak on impact that those people make
versus our impact but you know you look
at some of these people they make like a
few million a year and you don't even
know you've never heard of some of these
movies some of these people are in and
here we are you know educating or
entertaining hundreds of thousands of
people every day and we make less than
some of these you know c-class beasts B
Class movie movie stars that you movie
stars is a big term so yeah so I think
it goes both ways so it would be like
you getting paid like ten thousand
dollars per video plus you get ad
revenue on top of that yeah yeah yeah
yeah but yeah I think they really leave
it up to you to monetize it because
here's the thing I remember some smaller
youtubers you know Tanner J Fox yeah I
remember - nope Tanner J Fox was getting
like 15,000 views a day on his channel
and he was making like $300,000 a month
yeah wait from what redirecting his
audience Amazon FBA and he sold a
program on how to have it grown Amazon
it
and you don't think he was he was making
decent money like legitimately is making
decent money on Amazon FBA yeah he was
one of the first people in the entire
space to really go the coarse route yeah
made so much money doing course sales
you know so here's someone who who
honestly wasn't getting a lot of views
but he was the biggest in that space
yeah and just you know made a lot from
that and I think a lot of these guys
don't get I won't mention it but another
person was getting just on a regular
basis like 30 40 50 thousand views and
he was making like five hundred thousand
a month you're not doing that but it was
all in the back and it wasn't from ad
revenue no sure I think you know ad
revenue is a little component there but
depending on how you monetize and grow
in the back end you could make so much
right yeah but it just depends on what
you're doing behind the scenes that's
true versus a show or TV you know you
don't control the audience or anything
or try to sell but at the same time you
say well you can get followers like
people like oh I like that show so that
I want to watch them on future shows or
I want to follow them on Instagram or
things like that and then you can direct
but then you're relying on someone
else's brand deal for the mode that
strip it's like you know then didn't you
know product will come and say like hey
how much for this and you can charge on
that you know might YouTube is one of
those things that I think it's just
really up to you do you wanna make young
money doing that
yeah no no down yeah you know what's
interesting is one of the first people I
ever saw that really like was on TV and
then they went huge on YouTube and
unfortunately this guy's made a lot of
bad choices you know over the past few
years
Jake Paul you know he was on that Disney
show and then he you know does his
YouTube channel and simultaneously is
doing the Disney Channel thing and then
he's on YouTube and he was growing his
audience huge that was like 2,000 I want
to say 16 back then or 17 teams before
you know things went obviously way
downhill for that whole family but I
mean at that time dude it was like it
would that was transformative because no
one had done that really I don't know if
anybody that was on on a show and then
they built a huge YouTube audience at
the same time and lose from YouTube and
then the YouTube audience got him a
place on the show I think no yeah
because he had he was on vine vine I
think you can make an argument that
maybe vine helped him but uh he he was
on the Disney show and then he started
going YouTube when
buying us shutdowns all those Viners
came over here and they all went crazy
at that time I don't know if you
remember that time like there was him
and his brother then there's just so
many Viners I can glue a pawns and a
bunch came over and they had these huge
audiences and at the time the algorithm
would basically if you were hitting some
crazy like view the sub counts you would
get pushed more more at that time and it
just grew exponentially dude and yeah
those people writing that would tick
tock down oh that's the next way Charlie
to mail it to me Leo did someone see em
Mel Julio I don't know whatever whatever
her thing is okay sometimes I look at
the trending page you'll see some top 10
trending mm-hmm and it click on it like
I've never heard of this prison before
yeah and then I'm like wow they have
like two million subscribers I how many
videos do they do they're like four
videos like they have like 50 million
followers on tick-tock yeah well they
can just redirect you know that a small
person take talk they make a youtube
channel to get a million subscribers and
one YouTube like over another and their
videos get so many views yeah that puts
it on trending cuz it's like just so we
got to talk about one thing you made
trending last month did you ever think I
think multiple times did you ever think
you would be on the trending page of
YouTube that is like that this is where
I talk about like inspiration and like
expanding my mind like for the whole
space do when I saw that I'm just like
that's crazy
you know I mean it's amazing and then I
think after that I think I want say
Andre I think got on the training and I
think Kevin Kevin gone yeah got number
one was number one trending for like
almost 48 hours
whoa that was one of the days I think
got like 12 15,000 new subscribers in a
day yeah yeah clear value yeah okay
clear value was maybe one of the first
in finance to get on the trending page
oh I didn't even know the value and then
meet Kevin Andre me why Oh Jeff Rose was
another one who was on training for
really yeah it's yeah I feel like
there's there's a bit of a like you to
get on the trending
you have to hit so many different things
like not only do you have to have a
really popular time and it has to appeal
to anybody
yeah a good message to it okay if you
can't hit all and it's got to be
clickable with a good title Wow
so it's like you got it hit so many
different things to be on trendy you got
to do that within the first 48 hours
your video posting so if you can't hit
all of those it's not gonna it's not
gonna happen but no I'm just like that
wasn't that's just an amazing moment for
the space honestly like trending you
know cuz literally like when we kind of
got rolling with this like it was just
you know there was no such thing as like
the finance space on YouTube so just
non-existent and like to see where it's
at now where videos are getting on
trending dude that's just it I think
it's great it's becoming more mainstream
especially I think in each of it
initially I thought it was really
worried with everything going on in the
whole like the illness not everything
I'm like this is it I really felt like
it could this be the end it cuz I've
noticed all my videos on YouTube snobs
getting pushed as soon as that happens
yeah and there was no longevity and I'm
like all these videos that I spent so
long on they're just not getting pushed
him and it seemed like she was just
favoring like the newest content and why
don't you post everyday yeah I just
can't I can't do every day and do it
yeah so I was like you know is this it
but I'm gonna try to roll with it but it
turned out to be like this blessing in
disguise
yes absolutely shifted around it gave me
so much more to talk about so yeah for
more of this direction yeah you can go
with it no absolutely but yeah I mean
it's it's amazing and how many how many
channels are on the come-up right now
that are in that space where they're
getting a thousand a 10,000 views a
video right now it's amazing like just
in my niche which you know I've really
focused my channel last year to really
just around stock market investing now
it's amazing to see the massive quantity
of creators coming up and actually you
know fulfilling a dream of potentially
like making YouTube a career or you know
just being on social media in general or
you know making a part-time income
whatever it is now like it's amazing
no it's phenomenal see and with stuff
that is really important like people
should care about their money yeah
people should care about like because
it's gonna dick you like the amount of
money you have can dictate so much it's
gonna you know dictate where you live
what schools your kids go to where you
know what type of food you eat you know
where you eat it's where you vacation if
you vacation a money's gonna dictate all
that if you can give money to charity
everything you know so you know I don't
want to say our space is the most
important one on YouTube but it's hard
for me not to say the financial station
the space in general is not the most
important I'm just worried it's uh I
just don't want it to be a fad because I
think a lot of these things come with
their curbs everyone's interested in and
it kind of dies down goes genus
something else that people just put
their focus now it just happens to be
anything money you're the biggest in the
space and you know you're getting
anywhere from 300 to 600 K let's say a
video on an average video some are
getting you know all the way up to a
million but you know and that's really
large but it still you look at some of
these other spaces the makeup industry
yes I you you know you look at you know
many we're gonna say mr. beast he's like
maybe the king of YouTube break
didn't 10 million plus every video those
mr. beast videos appeal to everybody
yeah like you're a younger audience yes
sir even even if you're if you're five
years older than 50 you'd still watch
mr. Bies video yeah it's family-friendly
and no one can watch it
whether you're so smart or you're you
know nothing about no it's just you
could zone out and watch this video and
it's yeah with money it's like you have
to be interested in personal finance
yeah you have to you know at least know
some level of background just a little
bit mr. beast is to everybody so it
makes sense why his views are so on yeah
yeah finance and make it like anybody
can watch unless it's like some major
event it just happen and you can but I'm
having more more faith you know that
we're gonna get to a place where you're
getting a million views a video yeah
that's gonna be you know I already feel
like it's been a game-changer but you
know that's when we're talking about a
real massive space cuz you look at what
happened to gaming you know you know
there's you know obviously the few
people that are at the top of gaming
they get millions of views that's even
like a niche market you know how many
people I I've played video games
sometimes I don't really watch video
game you know videos and there's only a
certain segment of people that are
really into gaming like them so you know
all these markets aren't like that
massive you know make up in beauty he
has a lot of people that wear makeup and
and are into beauty but how many are
really
to it that they watch you know and you
know they this this creator over here
gets five million views a video so I
feel like all these markets from the
most part they're a lot of these are
still kind of niche downtown today
yeah you know a lot of people wear
makeup and they don't care to watch a
makeup video they just know you know but
yet they're pulling millions of you well
then you watch them for the personality
same like you day training let's just
say and just making comments like
PewDiePie yeah imagine it having like
your little face up in the upper right
you're trading stocks back and forth in
your minute elements yeah PewDiePie yeah
imagine that that might be the next wave
wait wait to see that yeah okay look at
the look at the arms do that just live
day trade make comments yeah that'd be
super good and I think you two would
probably push that content a lot I think
they see the value and people like
having good financial education yes but
but I think for day trading and stuff
like that they're gonna start oh yeah
there's no because people are treating
it like it's a gambling really treating
a gambling game and I think now it's so
unregulated that like especially in some
of these apps you can trade options with
new experimenting you just have to
select like I'm an intermediate investor
who wants you know it's just there's no
barrier to entry as long as you're 18
you could legally gamble on the stock
market
yep no it's it's it's a little scary
I'll be honest you know um but at the
same time hey if people are making money
they're making money so mainly would you
consider yourself a youtuber a stock
trader oh boy I would probably still
consider myself a youtuber first stock
market investors second just because the
majority of my time still is spent
around YouTube and YouTube related
activities but it's getting closer to
50/50 now but over time it's gonna flip
and I'm gonna even go further and
further
as far as time goes because eventually
you get so much money invested that it
doesn't matter what type of view counts
you're getting it's just will become
insignificant right you know where it's
like even if you're making a hundred K
from YouTube let's just say for instance
you've got 50 million already right
it's like was your time better spent
spending an extra hour thinking about
the YouTube video title and thumbnail
and the content there was a that hour
would have been spent better researching
companies so for right now I kind of
still consider myself a little bit more
like I like if somebody say what do you
do I would say I'm a youtuber and then I
would say I'm a stock market investors
second so but I think I think over time
eventually you get to a place where you
know yeah I think whatever you are it's
whatever you spend the most time on okay
that's how I feel and so I would I spend
the most time on YouTube
and sometimes I do think I'm like
imagine if I was spending all this time
just researching companies and I bring
out to my private group like the Private
Stock group now I have this list of DMS
I get every single night and I have to
get back to these people like they pay
to be part of the group and for me to
answer questions things like that right
and every night it takes me at least an
hour to to to get into that to get back
to all those people in DMS and all I
think about sometimes is I'm like what
if this hour too was spent looking into
other companies rather than getting back
to all these people you're good I'll try
that I just shut down down the
membership for a month yeah well you
can't really do that you can't just like
shut it down and they'd be like oh you
know do these people pay you know for a
year you know so I'm committed to it I
have to be committed to it you know I'm
a man of my word but I dude those
thoughts still go through my head I'm
like what if I what if I was reading any
annual report right now or listen to a
conference call sometimes I do listen to
a conference call while I'm responding
to DM z-- and stuff but it's
everything's like what what's there's a
perfect name for that in in the space
like a time time versus money aspect or
something like that yeah so but yeah you
tuber I would still consider myself is
first it was funny I asked Graham like
what he what he says he does when people
ask him you know how does he make a
living and he says he he would never say
you tuber he says he calls himself
well realist
I mean I'm in realistic um up to you and
asked you like Oh what do you do I got
the casinos or something you always say
I'm a youtuber yeah like if my neighbors
like when I'm into a new neighborhood
yeah yeah no the one part I don't think
about that is then you have to explain
cuz they like you like you can make
money from that like how do you make
money and then you get into this whole
thing that's why that revenue
4555 embarrassed of it at all like I'm
proud of what we built on YouTube and
what we're continuing to build but at
the end of the day that's the only thing
I knows me is like now I gotta kind of
that process again there's ads that are
shown before the videos and after the
videos are over and you make money off
those ads and it's only a very small
amount but when it's a lot of people
watching the amounts of bigger you know
I have to get into that whole thing what
are you doing real estate I'm an agent
Oh how's the market yes over here
yeah do you dabble in real estate at all
do you have rental properties and so uh
not rental properties but I'm up to well
we got two houses we're building right
now plus the house we own so I'm putting
more and more money into reals so you're
building houses yeah yeah well ones are
so second home one's gonna be the main
home and then the current home were
living in once the other Vegas home was
ready which is still gonna be for like a
year or so I'm trying to figure out if I
want to rent it I could maybe get like
$4,000 a month I think for it or I'm
trying to figure out if I want to just
turn it into like an office where I can
have you know either employees meet at
independent contractors and just have it
like a meeting spot because I don't
really have a formal office right now I
need some write-offs this year all right
if part of me is thinking like it might
be a good idea to go and invest in an
actual office space oh yeah but I want
it nearby I mean that's the only thing
is I don't know I like not having a
commute yeah and it's just like walking
into a room part of me is worried that
like you know people like think we're
filming in the dining room yeah at what
point do you become too like oh
commercial personalized and something
like that you know it might be too fancy
maybe people like let me know down below
in the comments or my opinion on that is
if you're coming up with
and you're coming up with the strategy
for the content the videos and all sorts
of things I don't think it really
matters that much where you're recording
it whether it's against the plain wall
or it says it's a sad or things like
that I think where some people get into
trouble is when they have the outsourced
all their content the ideas for the
content the titles the thumbnails
you know like a Gary Vaynerchuk right
now obviously like a legend on social
media in the business space but he
doesn't he's not coming up with any of
that you know he has a team doing that
and so it loses some of its authenticity
yeah and it just waters down the content
over time and it just doesn't get the
type of views it could potentially if
maybe he was doing that personally and
actually coming up with that so I think
you lose I think I think you might lose
that I don't think it really has much to
do with the backdrops or sets or
anything like that I think at the end of
day it's it's are you coming up with a
video there's also the overages it's the
mental just toll of like how much does
this cause to me every day
where can I use that instead and just
having no overhead just no expense it's
just and if you post a video it's not as
a profit but then you can also say well
what if that property appreciates to
four million over the next 10 years you
know that's traffic so then you can say
well I could keep that money in can
there are worse things you can put your
assets into that's that's it well that's
what justified this property yeah why is
that you know long term it's going to
appreciate it I think it's a good store
of cash we are cashing here it's safe
yep yeah I mean you could write that
property off and you know you know let's
say you get it from 1.8 and appreciates
- let's say it's a 2.5 over the next 10
years you know which would not be good
appreciation for LA on historical
standards and thinking le appreciate
it's actually probably more than I I'm
guessing probably yes okay next 20 years
yeah my guess and so yeah I mean cash
you know gets devalued every day as we
know yeah the printer goes and and yeah
I mean it might make a lot more
financial sense especially when you sort
of thing about the write-off side is a
nice place - amazing
so did you channel blow up like
instantly add a specific period of time
because I know it wasn't in the
beginning
yeah but or was it like a more grad
increase in views no for me it's always
been gradual I've never had a like whoa
he blew up like he made one change like
Graham went from two to three and then
there was like yeah great like Graham
you know he really had this time period
which I knew was gonna happen it's like
2018 all the way into nineteen like
really the back half of eighteen moving
into nineteen I was just watching him
and like he's about to go crazy and sure
enough it happened I've never had that
period I've just been you know steady
growth you know I've always the most
important I kind of thing I look at is
what's average views I'm pulling in per
video and if you just look over time
it's just kind of been like a steady
stream up it's never like I went Olsen
from like 5,000 views a video no I'm
getting a hundred thousand now no it's
just been steady it was like you know I
remember when I started pulling in like
10k consistently and then I was like 20k
and it was kind of like 40k then it was
like 60 K now I'm kind of at a stage
where I'm looking for like 100 K a video
and so yeah I've never had a like whoa
he blew up moment it's just always been
steady growth and that's one of the
things I've always kind of strived for
because I've always wanted people that
really like stick with me believe in my
investment philosophies respect my
investment philosophies and are willing
to watch my channel grow and watch me
grow and watch my investments grow and
hopefully you know people that watch my
channel make a lot of money yes as long
as I'm as long as I'm helping people
make money people don't forget about
that yeah coming back to you and I think
that's why I've just been able to
consistently grow year after year after
year is that the end of the day most of
the people watching my channel I think
we're making money as long as they're
sticking on my investment philosophies
and focusing on things I look at and so
therefore warm where people are like
okay
I watched him last year and I got this
game I'm gonna watch him this year and
as you get people angry if they lose
money no really what happened wit in
March March and April when just the
markets tanked II did you ever get
anybody being like listen then I
listened to your investment I invest my
fifty thousand it's all the money I have
it's down to you already you know twenty
what's up man not really cuz I something
I always try to explain to people is the
volatility of the market like you have
to be ready for this like this is not
just a one-way game you know and I think
that's where you know I could probably
get a lot more sales for my private
group if I was like just talked about
the ups but
something I love to talk about it as a
downs like mistakes I may in the market
like you have to be ready to like go
down on money if the market gets really
bad for a month or a few months or a
year you must have to be ready for that
so I never really get that type of
negativity I think because I explained
it well I explained you know the risk in
stocks you know I always put it as worst
case scenario I'm like where's case
scenario you put money in the stock that
goes to zero like I even bring that out
in video sometimes and just kind of
putting in people's mind like dude you
can lose everything you know and it's
like that for any investment and I think
because I bring it around that way it is
another reason why the communities just
add a higher like intelligence level
then maybe some of these other you know
channels that are out there because my
people understand like the risk and the
reward and that's something I really try
to bring it out and that's why I never
really even scared to talk about my
failures to me goes by talking about my
failures it like makes people realize
wow there's risk in here so do you think
you have to be an intelligent to be a
stock trader invest investor I think you
have to have a certain level of
intelligence in terms of really
emotional intelligence I don't think
it's necessarily like you know how to do
calculus level blah blah blah I think
it's more just like having that
emotional control to you know Graham we
were talking about a little earlier you
know I think in this podcast where it's
just like knowing not to get too
emotional
everything's objectively yeah if you
would objectively not try to get in and
out because you feel an emotion today
about something in really just just
going off the the fundamentals the
emotions in being able to stay
disciplined is the most important thing
it really is it's the most important
thing when it comes to investing you
know I could teach as somebody all the
strategies in the world and you know do
this look there's no stock if they're
not disciplined they're gonna go off the
rails I'm gonna do some crazy stuff
which you know some people get into and
some people make short-term money up
there you know the Wall Street bets
community sometimes I mean most the time
that's bad so yeah do you ever buy
stocks and then sell like the next day
yeah in terms of short-term very rarely
because I looked into these companies
fully understand the fundamentals and
usually if I'm buying I'm buying for
multi years out I will sometimes sell
earlier like usually I'm looking three
to five years out in a calm
I could potentially sell B for 35 years
but it's because usually like the
fundamentals changed with the business
model so it's not the same company about
into like you know just different
decisions were made it's like whoa this
is not the same or if it went up too
fast
there's some advice yeah yeah and
sometimes that happens with stocks you
know they just go up way more than you
ever expected way too fast the valuation
maybe doesn't make sense and it's like
just take a profit so you know that's
kind of the way I view it
what were your biggest wins and biggest
losses in the market biggest wins and
biggest losses oh boy so my biggest win
currently is Tesla unless my biggest win
currently like someone might not ever
know uh if I sold it today yeah because
it's well over a six-figure profit and I
don't think I've ever made six bigger
profit from stock ever mm-hmm I don't
recall I made five figures many times in
many stocks like Cabela's was a great
investment of mine back in the day
Trinity industries cirrus logic has been
a good investment of my multiple times
throughout the market trying to think of
some others this has been you know a lot
of a lot of successes the worst one was
GoPro it was my worst talk ever you know
and that was well documented on the
channel that was a fun one to go through
you know that one's just like everything
didn't work out like they failed at
everything and then my worst one
currently which is actually I think my
one of my only red stocks is CCL and
that one's massively negative right now
I think we're down like well price you
buy another 40s like 41 yeah we're down
like 50% if not a little over 50% on
that one that one's just gone so bad but
but have you thought about doubling down
no and just being like let's invest more
once I thought about it and I thought
about it even lower but then today I
just don't want to risk more money in
that one yeah yeah I'm just kind of like
more confident in other stocks yeah
exactly I'm like I look at some of these
other stocks unlike this more outside in
this stock desktop I don't want to buy
more CCL so but I try not to judge
myself too hard on CCL I judge myself a
lot more hard on what happened with
GoPro and that was more like a 2016-17
investment rather than CCL because CCL
got caught into a once in a hundred year
like roni roni situation and that just
like you know what are you gonna do like
the cruise industries
always like a very profitable industry
even if there's a normal
like yeah business is down but it's not
down like you're where you're shot down
so but yeah that's that so that's my
reason then wouldn't this be a really
good time to just throw some money in
them we'll the problem is we don't know
how this is gonna recover because we've
never been through it so there's a lot
of people very confident that we're
gonna you know get back really strong
really fast I don't know I don't know if
we're gonna have a second wave and what
happens if we do have a second wave in
the economy act she has to shut down
again
yeah no economy shut said again I mean
it's the drop is gonna be worse than I
think the first time but I just can't
imagine I think at that level they would
just say well we don't have a choice
we're gonna have to get through this
yeah and now we've worked a little bit
more prepared we have more information
and I suppose you know handle I just
can't imagine shredding a delegate let's
hope not
I really can't imagine yeah let's hope
not but the other thing is a consumer
psyche you know if you know it takes off
again you have a certain segment of
customers who are already not engaging
with businesses right now because
they're scared for health reasons they
don't want to go out right and that's
that's you've got this segment over here
if the segment that's in the middle
they're like I'll go out but I won't do
as much you have the segment of
customers who don't care if we have the
Ronit take off again really bad then
that segment still gonna definitely not
come out this thing that's in the middle
probably gonna move more right to not
come out as well which will you know
make for a much longer recession and in
this segment is probably to move to the
middle and that's where I get scared not
just in terms of always the government
gonna shut us down again but what's the
consumer psyche around going out going
to my City Vegas going to the beaches
going to the restaurants if we have a
take back off big time again in the
numbers balloon and the hospitals get
filled that you know that remains to be
seen
and so I think it's um you know I think
it's something you have to think through
right now and I think it's why you still
have to keep some cash around even
though you know assets are continuing
increase right now I think real estate
prices were up the last couple months
which is like who what how in this
environment all it is yeah
and you look at the stock market last
word like up huge and it's a ghost of
Hyde yeah you know like that's crazy but
um but at the other day I think with
that risk you have to keep you should
always keep this I love
love cash but I think you still have to
write now because there's that risk man
if this takes back off in the fall I
mean if the numbers are still growing
right now and then what happens if they
really start you know growing
exponentially I don't know you know we
could be optimistic though let's hope
for the best
I'm optimistic yeah and Graeme your
biggest one was on Tesla too right
overall yes Tesla hmm that 260 so was my
average 258 average by Oh average price
yeah so I think it's interesting I think
we should discuss as Graham's been
investing more and more stocks lately
I've been investing more and more real
estate high the whole world is screwed
up right now like what is going on but I
would like talk to us for a moment about
you in investing like what's inspired
you to put more and more money into
stocks I think it's just full for so
I've known for a long time I need to be
more diversified or what everything went
into real estate and I started thinking
like at this point I could take less
risk and just I need to diversify and do
some say for instance say for investment
then when everything dropped so
dramatically I'm like okay well I have
all this cash that I've been sitting
waiting for through my like a good real
estate deal is just sitting there I may
as well start buying in so I made the
mistake of like I didn't want to put all
my money at once yeah so I started
buying and bit by bit but as I started
buying in prices kept going up and so I
kept buying and kept buying and kept
buying and prices kept you know
continuing to go on but in that I made
some good investments and I made some
that you know I bought a little bit too
high danny's was one of them okay they
just bought too high a lot of the rest
Cheesecake Factory I got in pretty low
my cheesecake wherever you sit down with
I take her simple cake right yeah cake I
think I must make it better than 9:30
percentage she's okay
so there's some of my mom a lot Boeing
was another one 128 Boeing and I think
it's been a 30 grand or 30 or 40 grand
Boeing at 128 yeah Boeing Boies one a
few stocks I feel like you know they
kind of got caught up too much in the
whole storm because Boeing had issues
before like they already had issues 737
max but then on top of that you had this
and airplane orders are gonna get pushed
out for probably the next few years
what
and of the day there's two companies in
the world in the world that really
dominate the whole you know industry
it's them and it's I'm an air boss and
then also there are military so the
government would never allow them to go
under No so when I looked at that one I
was like this is dumb that I don't buy
Boeing stock especially when I saw it
under 100 because I'm like they're not
going under they're not going under now
you know but yeah that was a great
pickup by yes so then when it dropped
below to 170 mark I think I bought more
on like 175 okay um so that's been
that's been a good one for me but I just
see like right now I'm looking at how
much is my time worth and we're gonna
get the best return for my time we're
gonna I feel like my time is not best
spent right now going and try to find a
real estate deal here where I can make
you know it's gonna take me a few months
to find a good deal you know close on it
renovate it my time is better spent just
earning less money of my investments by
doing something safer yeah so I feel
like there's more potential now in
hard-hit stocks and just index fund
investing for my time yes Ben real
estate investing right now yeah right
now yep no that makes that makes us
that's why but a lot of these companies
- honestly I just like cheesecake
factory is a perfect example where the
stock price went down like 80 percent or
something crazy like that you know and I
would go to the Cheesecake Factory every
single time I go there there's a line
out the door oh if I can't be the only
one going and just like ordering for the
cheesecake there's a line and I'm like
this is gonna come back big so that's
why it that was Cheesecake Factory
American Express was another company I
didn't really want her that's thing up
another I think 25 or 30 percent
American experience yeah that's not
really dangerous I got something else I
got sense where I can express those
customers are not going to be as
affected no by this American Express is
continuing to grow I like their credit
cards a lot great JP Morgan oh yeah
who's another company um the banks are
almost government back yes point hi JP
Morgan bank us so a lot of these banks
and was like gee I like JP Morgan I
think they got a good bank they got a
good credit card you know but I throw
money in them so a lot of these
companies I did just buy because I felt
like I used them myself I liked them
Wells Fargo would I had lost money in
Wells far so I Bible money wells
thinking like oh yeah I'm just gonna get
there I think a horribly run company but
they're not lying to change their image
I'm like it can't get much worse I'm
here right well it went down Wells
Fargo's my biggest loss I think we're GE
i like they're pretty neck-and-neck
okay but no I got a really important
question a so when Graham Steffen goes
to Cheesecake Factory do you buy a piece
of cheesecake because you know the
margins they're making on that are
insane we got it we got a coupon there
was a Black Friday deal where you lie
like a $25 gift card you get two free
cheesecakes oh I'm like then it's like
425 bucks yeah the cheesecakes for $8
each so it's really like it's worth it
yeah that's that's gotta be able the
main place they make money man then that
slice of cheesecake it cost $8 yeah
eight doughnuts
yeah for a slice of cheesecake it's
really good cheesecake that but also it
is I'd like to speak factory because
their portions are so big for that sir
they were 15 dog salad fries yeah you
split that in half it's really 750 m
meal but look at Cheesecake Factory mint
it's trading at $24 if there was 50 and
look at just it was a very steady
yup my board is holding six percent
dividend and now it's trading in half
but I look at this just as someone who's
not died into it stocks and you like
okay it was a $50 stock mm-hmm and I
think yeah people are gonna go back to
the cheesecake yeah but even if they
don't even if fewer people go you know
70% of the people end up coming back if
it's a 24 it should be 35 yeah stop
great suit how good is that logic I'm
like it's trading at 25 why can't I just
go on it should be worth 35 based on the
previous yeah as long as business
returns that's the biggest key but at
the end the end that's another thing
like you could make money in the stock
market without being on the level that I
am or I try to you know train people to
get to that level the reason I really do
what I do and I research these companies
I listen Congress calls I put in all the
time is to way outperform the stock
market you know the public count it was
like fidelity has had like what a 74
percent game that's why I do it you know
not just from the perspective of like
you know but you can still make money in
the stock like you you're making money
like you're doing very well for yourself
right you could buy
index fund you can still like no matter
which way you slice it you have to
participate in the stock market I feel
like I feel like if you're not you're
just losing money yeah like you know
what I mean and you don't have to do day
trading you don't have to do any of that
crazy stuff you know it doesn't work for
90 plus percent of people right you
don't have to go there but if you're not
participating in some way in the stock
market it's usually just a big mistake
it really is it really is I felt like
such a genius though and in March
because I know all this cash
yes waiting for real estate yeah and
then it dropped and I was just like I
did it but I did but I didn't invest
like I looked back at that and just yeah
whoa but I started buying in there but
still I feel like a part of me and then
just like I feel like I missed some of
that run up yeah back I could save so
much money if I did buy a bit but you
never know you know in hindsight things
might be lunch when did you first meet
Graham and what was your impression of
him so first met Graham and think it was
2017 and I can't remember if he reached
out amoeba snapchat right no no I think
it was email oh could have been email
yeah yeah yeah it could have been email
at that time I was kind of like I was
different back then I was kind of like
in this zone where I'm like I don't
really want to talk to anybody that's a
creator yeah I didn't like mix with
anybody and I'm completely opposite now
like I reach out to like youtubers that
are on the come up and try to like help
them and guide them and things like that
but back then I was very like I'm in my
own lane I'm doing my own thing don't
bother me I don't care who you are but
you know Graham was one of the people
that I was like I was open to and you
know he had a I don't know what his
channel size was back then but it was
you know a smaller channel and he I
remember I think the first time we met
you came over my house yeah and whatever
house I was living in at that time I
think he was in Vegas you know somewhere
but yeah and it was it was awesome you
know we met we talked I remember that
yeah I think my parents are
yes in your backyard yeah yeah and I
remember you know this is a funny story
about Graham there's our first time
meeting and you know we're talking and
stuff and then like 20 minutes in he's
like listen do you mind if I do this on
I kind of were this specific like laptop
there's a really good deal on being HP
yeah yeah something like right around
then he's like do you mind if I do this
real quick it's just a really good deal
and I was like go for it you know
typical Graham stuff and fashion he's
gonna save some money even though his
first time meeting somebody but no it
was good we talked a bit and and then we
kind of built our relationship from
there later on down the road we did a
conference together I remember it was at
2018 which was a funny story about that
is you know our channels were at very
different places back then our personal
brands were at very different places I
remember how you remember how hard it
was to sell tickets there oh yeah
incredible I mean I think it didn't like
the name of it yeah there was there were
soul really building we had yeah we had
no clue we had no clue what we were
doing our personal brands were just we
were all still don't like to come up
yeah we could pack that place for like a
thousand nights nowadays but like back
then it's just like it was ridiculous
but no and that was fun and we've just
you know built our relationship from
there and he's one of the few like
friends I actually have on YouTube where
I like it's like not just about like
YouTube I'm not just like trying to use
him as like you know person I'm like you
know I was actually a friendship there
and I don't have a lot of people in the
spaces very few I have that or you know
I can really call friends because my
biggest thing is like I don't like to
have a lot of people that I'm not one of
those type of people that likes to have
a lot of people in my life because my
time is limited and so I always look at
it as if if if I want to conversate with
you or talk with you on some order a
regular basis like you have to be
important you know what I mean because
you know we do think about money right
and if you're spending all this time
with all these different people at the
end of day you're not really thinking
about you know what's the next let's be
friends with someone who lifts you up
yeah bounce ideas off yeah like I like
that we could we could talk and then I
feel like I leave that conversation to
who I get so many new ideas to think
about like it's true they don't like you
know just hanging out with people where
all of a sudden you feel like you're
just yes draining yeah it's a different
perspective and honestly there's not a
lot of people that really think
like us so to find somebody else that is
like on say the same wavelength is like
amazing
because we're you know and I remember my
wife was talking about she's like
sometimes I feel like I can't really you
know interrupt you and Graham when
you're talking because you guys are just
on this whole other like level of
talking about algorithm in nominal
details and like you know we get into so
and so in depth on some of these
subjects but it's nice to have some you
know somebody in the space that's really
thinking about the kind of stuff I'm
thinking about in like weekends you know
because it's really not like once you
get into this it's like if I don't yes
phase no 100% not to call anybody but be
people are all just like how can I make
money like right now how can I make
money and that's it
that's it yep in a longevity and that's
another thing I've been wanting to build
relationships with people that are gonna
be here for the like the long-term
that's the kind of the way I view it and
I'm like III don't want to build
relationships with people that are just
you know like here today and gone
tomorrow tasting most of them on social
media
yeah and then they're big for a year and
yeah just they cash out yeah they find a
way to cash out yeah they're done yeah
yeah yeah cuz I plan on being here for
the long term so I'm like if I want to
build relationships in the space whoever
I want to build relationships with it
has to be people that like I like one
but two also I think are gonna be here
for the long term I think it's really
important like you know there's a lot of
quick money people on social media
there's want to make quick money and get
out and you know that's if that's what
they want to do this what they want to
do but I'm just like why not build a
long-term personal brand that people
appreciate and love for you know it
takes decades it yeah it takes a lot of
work it takes a lot of care it takes a
lot of attention and in on social media
the thing is you can scale some people
can scale really fast if they you know
figure out something and then they make
some money and then they dip because
they're like they give content to you
know a lot of people you know they make
a million dollars or getting a
reputation yes it's a lot more common
they make money until something happens
yeah
I know yeah yeah 100% yeah where they
were using shady techniques from the
beginning
yep that we knew it was coming and I got
ya oh we've talked about many people who
in the space a thousand times and we
always can call it out we're like this
person's going on Nexus pricks is good
though yeah yeah it's just what happens
man but you know the there's there's a
few key players in the financial space
that are gonna be here for a long term
and there's there's a lot of people on
the come-up and we're gonna see who can
who can take it to that level and get to
you know bigger numbers so but yeah I
know but uh you know Graham's awesome
man that's all I get to say you know my
favorite people yeah one of my favorite
people Thanks um are you do you admire
grams per gallon II do you think he goes
too far with it and are you frugal in
any way yeah I think gram goes too far
with this I've shared this with them
before I think gram is way too
conservative with his money so my kind
of views on money and money comes my
ghosts but as long as you got like this
this month I have a I have an on
scarcity mindset nowadays and I don't
mean to go to a place where you're
spending every dollar comes in or even
close to that because I don't even get
remotely close to that level but I will
say for you know Graham is is too much
man it's too much for the type of money
oh my gosh but I'm like yeah but at the
same time I've learned to respect it
because it is who Graham is he wouldn't
be where he is now without that - that's
true yes I played that to my favorites
it's funny I actually make money from
saving money yeah exactly brand yeah
yeah because I've saved so much it makes
me more money we talk about saving I
always talk about myself as a frugal
person and my wife you know is she she
always thought of me as a really frugal
person and told you know we started
hanging out with Graham and she's like
oh he's an ex I think I think I think he
sometimes just gotta get out of that
scarcity mindset you don't I don't like
I said I don't even spend remotely close
to what I make in a month not even it's
not even like close I invest most my
money or it goes to cash one of those
two areas but I'm willing to spend on if
I want to spend money it has to mean
something to me though
you know I don't just spend money to
spend money you know there's certain
things like I don't honestly care that
much about clothing I probably bought
these shorts I'm wearing four
thirty forty bucks I got this shirt at
the win for I don't know 40 bucks that's
not like I wear designer suits or this
watch I'm wearing probably cost me three
or four hundred dollars I don't wear a
ten thousand twenty thousand dollar
watch because the ten thousand $20,000
watch for me means nothing in in respect
I don't need to watch yeah yeah I know
you love watches for me I'm just like I
literally don't care I just want it to
look cool I don't care if it's a Rolex
or wear this brand so I am about like
spending my I bought Tesla's very
expensive write a performance what's
your day what's the car you take yeah I
brought them all X but that's because I
came with the family although they went
back with my brother-in-law but you know
that's a very expensive the mall X is
like 100 K the mall 3 was like 60 K
that's a lot that's like 160 K and 2
cars but those means something to me
I've really enjoyed those right
especially the model 3 you don't take on
you any gram it's like it's fun man so
as long as it means something to me I'll
spend the money in as long as it's not
going overboard that's my biggest thing
so yeah yeah yeah Graham he's extra man
just a couple more questions did you go
to college I did go to college yeah for
like two and a half years went to like
Community College and they you dropped
out yup then I dropped out I started
working a quick trip and also call just
so dang expensive I had to pay my own
way in Community College and that was
fairly cheap I was able to pay with that
without going debt yeah but yeah I would
I had to pay my way through University
and I was just looking at and I was like
I started a quick trip and I was gonna
make like 4050 K year and just a Schmo
sent money so I was like you know forget
this I don't wanna take out a bunch of
debt go to university and kind of go
that route so I started doing the quick
trip thing and then I started investing
simultaneously most of that money that
was coming in and that's how I built my
first nest day that's how I started my
business that's how I started my YouTube
channel and it was immediately worth it
a hundred percent yeah yeah because I
got that job whereas already making
decent money which I was like 20 21 and
40 50k in Arizona goes a long way right
especially during you know that was rate
coming out of the Great Recession so
jobs are still hard to come by so
getting that following that money into
stocks and just getting the gains and
there's like keeping that money going it
was a game changer I
I don't like look back and like I regret
that like that was a great decision and
because I wouldn't be able to build up
that nest egg I feel if I went to
college it would have put me further
behind the eight-ball cuz I would have
taken out debt how to pay debt down
rather than invest that money it would
have slowed the process I probably
wouldn't be able to work at quick trip
and go to university at the same time so
yeah looking back it was the best it was
one of the best decisions I ever made
financially for me was it actually drop
off would you rather fight one
horse-sized duck or a hundred duck-sized
horses a hundred duck-sized horses duck
sized horses or one horse-sized duck one
horse-sized ox you got a big duck or you
have a hundred small horses I think I'd
rather do one big one because I could
focus on just that one person I'd rather
just focus on the one big one and also I
would feel I feel bad about myself
beating up a little
I'm just a small little cute horse these
are these are feral horses though still
let's just go against the big clown
first person to say that
let's go against the big one and I'll
focus on that one it might eat me alive
but we'll go for that one okay the next
one though is sigh what what is it is
cereal a soup oh yeah a cereal soup
cereal soup oh shoot that's deep by such
a deep question a surrealist soup I'm
gonna say no no it's hot as a hot dog a
sandwich the hot dog sandwich yes I I
would say a hot dogs I said it's not a
sandwich I mean it
hot dogs a hot dog but if we're gonna
consume put it in a group I feel like
it's a sandwich because it's got two
piece of bread on each side and it's a
meet in the middle
uh-huh I could consider too Sam I said
it wasn't a sandwich because the two
pieces of bread are connected or
connected oh but you can disconnected I
know they come connected okay yeah I can
see that and the final one is what was
the first person that was milking a cow
trying to do or whoa why did they do
that
yeah they were bored I'll be honest so
you know back there what's this thing
yes sir school yes back in the day it
was boring let's be honest like there
was no TV there was no internet people
are bored what are the heck you're gonna
do you're just sitting there looking at
the clouds all day okay
I mean if he do see an utter it's hard
not to think yeah I kind of mess around
down there I'd be afraid I get kicked
but hey I think it was boredom I think
boredom good you get your finger or your
hand guys thank you so much for watching
and do you have your two free stocks on
weeble I don't know okay no rolling yeah
get two free stocks I'll say you could
use the Pearl link down below get your
two free stocks we've been talking about
the stock market this entire time feed
your two free stocks and weeble make
sure to destroy the like button
subscribe button and notification bell
link to your channel down below Jax
information down below this just go down
below smash the thumbs litter ate that
one so thank you so much for watching
and until next time the next time I use
the higher episode all three of us are
like this long episode our arms is like
this I could not I was trying not to go
with both elbows cuz I like that would
look really bad so that was all that was
a great episode so much thanks for
having me that was more on grave and I
literally haven't done a video since
2018 so it's fun to do something